les examens c'est beaucoup plus strict
aussi en fonction du français même les
profs le disent tout le temps j'arrive
pas à croire comme la moitié de la
classe a couler les étudiants du
collégial le reconnaissent beaucoup
d'entre eux ne maîtrisent pas les règles
de base en grammaire en syntaxe en
ponctuation c'est le cas de 40 % d'entre
eux et leurs enseignants le répètent
depuis des années après 12 ans de
grammaire normalement il devrait avoir
acquis un certain bagage il faut
améliorer l'enseignement du français en
continuité du primaire au secondaire au
collégiales c'est ce que disent les
expertes mandatés par Daniel Beckham à
l'automne 2021 pour revoir le continuum
de français ça se fait pas du jour au
lendemain vous comprendrez donc ça c'est
vraiment une action concertée avec mon
collègue monsieur Drainville à
l'éducation puis avec les autres
collègues évidemment des ministères
concernés le rapport d'une centaine de
pages et ses 35 recommandations ont
passé un an sur les tablettes du
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
la nouvelle ministre en a pris
connaissance juste avant Noël elle fait
de la maîtrise du français une priorité
ça fait partie d'une action globale et
d'un plan d'action globale qu'on voit
éventuellement dévoiler d'ici le mois de
juin la Fédération étudiante collégiale
Satan a des résultats concrets dès
l'automne d'assurer que les cours de
renforcement en français soient
disponibles pour la population étudiante
qui en est le besoin et avant même le
qui commence les cours de littérature le
rapport était accueilli tièdement par
les syndicats qui représentent ceux et
celles qui enseignent la littérature
invoquant que la langue devrait être
maîtrisée avant les études supérieures
et on pense que ce cours de renforcement
là devrait être crédité parce que en ce
moment il n'est pas associé à des
crédits la plupart des étudiants qui
sont motivés et réussissent parce que
ils vont lire les textes parce que ils
vont prendre le temps de se corriger la
solution devrait aborder de front le
recours aux outils faire un meilleur
usage des dictionnaires certes mais
aussi des logiciel S et correcteurs le
moi à l'époque où j'allais à l'école
c'est tous les profs même mon prof de
maths m'encerclé les fautes que je
faisais en français on veut faire de la
maîtrise du français l'affaire de tout
le monde ici Anne-Louise despaty
Radio-Canada Montréal